A long time ago, I was a child playing video games.
One of the best parts about video games was the ability to modify the game.
Change how it works, change the way the game was played, change the exact type of game that you played.
Eventually modding got so involved that you didn't recognize what you were playing in the first place, and along came those few gems,
that were just delightful pieces of mods that made the experience totally worth it.
What the.. frick..
(2008 ALL YOUR BASE remix)
If that song doesn't date when this was made then I don't know what does.
This is "Scientist Slaughterhouse".
Now, this game.. or this modification of a game, is off of the original Half-Life engine,
which was made back in 1998. This mod was made in the early 2000s, I believe,
and it's entire objective, is about slaughtering the scientists in the game.
I absolutely love this, and the game was discontinued, which is a goddamn shame.
Well, maybe it's not, maybe it's not stupid fun. I haven't played this in years.
but what I remember of it, is that it was just absolutely wonderful. If you like the idea of those whacking games and the
gratuitous violence that comes with it, then you will like this game, because that's all it is. I swear.
That's all it is.
You can shut up- Okay. There we go. Now- oh my god. Number one. It's not even in the right resolution. Hang on,
Lemme do this real quick.
Alright, so if you don't know what this is, and if you don't know what Half-Life is,
There's...
*Mark trails off as the site intercom says something unintelligible*
I'm sorry. Oh, hi. Hello. There's really nothing I could do to explain what it is.
Oh yeah. Oh power me up baby.
Oh, give me the juice!
Yeah, I love the energy armor's S U C C.
Yeah, okay. Alright. Yeah, here we go. Yeah, it's just-
*wheeze*
This is literally it.
That's all there is!
It's just a game with an entire infinite possibility of different ways that you can annihilate scientists from the game Half-Life.
That's it.
Antimatter Pul- *mark breaks into laughter*
pulverizer mode!
*Mark unleashes fury upon a scientist*
Ion Discharge Cannon Mode. *more fury*
Gluon Gun!
*less enthusiastic fury*
Antimatter Puvl- alright, okay, so
Yes- Oh!
Shooty! (x5)
male voice: OHMYGAWD, WE'RE DOOMED!!
Yeah, oh..
I forgot there were scientists under the elevator-
It's been so long since I've played this particular "game".
Now I can- Now I can long jump. Yeah, I forgot there were..
*giggly* I forgot there were scientists down here..
I forgot!
Okay, yes, so if you thought that was it oh you just have one gun and that's gonna be it
The answer is no whoa. Whoa. Oh
Okay, you can shut down thank you, okay, what is this do I forget
oh, oh, OHOHOHOHOHO
There you go
What does this one do?
OH I see- hehehehe
Oh my God!
Incendiary warhead
Ha-BOW!
*laughing*
PLASMA BOOOOMB!
Oh my GOD!
EMP, you say?
EMPeepee
*explosions*
OHOHOHOHO
You shouldn't run into that my bud. Alright so Half-Life is an old game. Oh
what is this?
Ouu!
Where am I? Oh
I forgot there's a lot of loading... The game's old
So like, you know how loading screens and engines didn't used to be a thing
It kind of is now- look at that sky box! We seem to be on an aircraft carrier of some sort.
I'm sure this is normal. Wait. Hang on. Let me line up the crosshairs
Hello!
Hey, good to see ya.
*gunshots*
Okay... *chuckling*
*Imitates gunshots and laughs*
Oh alright that was- that was fun, that was very fun.
That was fun. Test fire? Oh, goodbye.
*laughing*
Alright go go buddy, go go. Come on. Where you goin'? Where you goin'? Where you goin'?
Oh shit! Um...
I don't think I was supposed to do that. I'm not sure how I get back now
*laughing*
I don't think I was supposed to fall in... Ugh.
Shit okay. Well, that's weird. Is there a load? There we go. Okay back here
I guess no this is fine moving on to a different area because that's not where we want this piece button Oh
Oh, oh oh, oh, oh oh oh, oh
Oh, I see oh yeah, you should be worried. Oh I see. Oh
I
see
God, I miss half-life! Half-life was this shit! I'm gonna say it outright half-life
Was this shit one of my favorite games of all time love the imagination and my god valve. What are you doing?
What are you doing? Half-life 3 you got to do it at some point you can't leave us all hanging forever here, man
Whoa, that's a that's a quake portal
Hello
What's going on in there? Oh, that don't look good. Well, that don't look good at all. That's probably one of those not good things. Oh no!
Hi
Don't walk into the beam
Don't walk into the-. Well, you're not gonna walk into the beam, are you? Hey, you shouldn't walk into this beam here
Whoa
Okay, what's in here?
Ou! excuse me, Oh disruptive shield avoid contact
oh ow! owie! owwww
I didn't know- AAAA!
Hi buddy, hey, how you doing? I
weeeeeee
Aw, I lost my jump assist I lost it so goodly. All right. Uh-oh. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh
Well, that's not what I wanted. That's not what I wanted at all. Can I get another one?
Please pretty please put another scientist on the platform, please
Aaaand squoosh.
Shouldn't be laughing at that I should but that's what this game does to you
Oh, well, that's what this mod does to you
it gives you a feeling of godly power the kinds that you shouldn't actually have and yet you do, and I know not why I
enjoy it so... Oh, what is this?
It's a flamethrower
It's literally just a flamethrower and then there's a button...
Huh? Oh wait
[Scientist's dialogue overlaps]
Scientist: Why are you leaving me here...?
Mark: What a big baby.
wHERE did you go?!
Oh
I didn't do that. That wasn't even me. Okay, caution extreme heat keep clear. What am I launching? Whoa. Oh
Shit. Whoops. Bye. Be careful. You guys better. Be careful. You guys better. Be careful
I think I'm getting Wallops about the volcano if I'm not mistaken. Oh, oh
Oh
Oh my god
That's why I should not have power in case it wasn't obvious
I should not have I just should. All right. Let's get me out of here. I've taken a bit of damage
I don't want to do too much else damage to my poor innocent body. Oh
Hi
How are you? How are you doing? Not so good apparently according to your stump of a head
Now what's funny about this game?
Is it got more sophisticated?
The longer it went on like the more they updated the game
The more sophisticated it became no one conquers the world alone for us
Nothing is impossible like it seems weird to say but yeah the game did in fact become a lot more sophisticated
A gas chamber? I don't like the sound of that. Okay. Alright. Oh
They just vanish, oh they just go into the ether. Oh, they just disappear out of this universe- What's this do?
What does this button do?
Alright, so that's pretty standard
Okay, alright everyone do the flop, all right so cool good. Yeah so Nephilim, oh shit
Nephilim wave. Oh
Right
They're all so dancey, they're excited
The lure of of half-life is also just as bizarre as sometimes the game
Thinking about the headcrabs and all that stuff and the combine and all hey
Hey buddy. "Green emitter?" Oh wait
'Please don't mess with my laser turret.' Oh, I wouldn't DARE...
How about you buddy? G-man. G-man!
All right, whatever just back to you buddy, all right all your base are belong to us
You have no chance to survive make your time
All right. Good. Great. Yeah, good. Hey shaadi Gunny. What does this do? Oh, I'll save you I
Tried what? I'm sorry
Hey, you didn't tell me that was gonna happen
Man, I got so many memories of playing half-life
So many memories, I can't even explain to you how far this brings me back because it really really does. Oh
Shit. Oh
Shit oh shit
What does it do what it's just to kill you it's a kill you Oh,
What the hell? Whoa, I bugged it. I- I most certainly bugged it. I bugged it.
That's not supposed to happen. That's- that's not- that's not what you want. Oh!!!
No
Oooo tractor beam.
Oh, yeah come with me
Scientist: It appears that you need medical attention right away.
Mark: I do...
Scientist: Let's try this.
Mark: Ow.
Yes.
[singing] Baby I'm back! I'm on a roll,
I'm back baby,
Baby I'm back. Oh
Where am I going, baby? I'm back mom. Oh
Shit Oh, what is this? I know what this is. There's a weird alien bug launcher, which I love
Power overwhelming? Oh wait. Fuel. Oh, oh I get it
Oh, I know what you want
You want me to set up a bunch of things for you to get this to under waiver?
Do this the thing in the stuff and that the thing you got it? Oh wow Snorks
snark
I'm back, baby
Whoa shit. Wait, no no, no go back. I gotta get power overwhelming
There we go
What have I done Oh
Oh
Shit. Oh that that's probably not good for the scientists outside. It is loud out there. It is really loud. It's it's quite loud. Oh,
Shit. Oh
My god Oh
Weird weird. Oh, they're fighting each other. Oh shit. It's a war
Alright cool goods war its war. I like war not really but okay. I'm out of here. Oh, okay. Good good
Okay save what's fantastic about mods and I kind of want to get back into the world of modding
Especially modding way too much in games, which is always fun
But the best thing about mods is it allows you to get more value out of individual games, you know
You can have half-life 2
But it can last you a long
Long time because so many people are in the community are making cool things like it just kind of never ends
Whoo?
That don't make the most sense but whatever. All right what else we have here, what's this kaboom? Oh
Shit, what did I do?
See, this is what it means it get more sophisticated as time went on this this mod was like updated month by month
And so whenever they like added a new release to it. Hey
You know
they would do this shit for totally for free and it would just make game for the love of like making shit and I and
I love that. I love that. It's not sustainable in any way because people got to eat but man, I love hobbyist mod makers
That's the coolest stuff. It's just so fun. It just makes it all really really fun
And it makes games more fun because you can feel the community
that's all a part of it and you could feel how many people are like loving the game and enjoying the game and just like
Hey, there's something on your shirt. Hey your face
Landed on you
Where are you?
Turns out they're all dead. Okay, cool. I
Didn't realize it was like a wall of fire approaching you oh
Omae wa mou shinderu.
(You are already dead.)
NANI?!
That's still going on out there. Okay bear that's I guess that's just forever now
Can I go turn that off because that is obsessively too loud. Oh my god
Thank you, yes, thank you. Thank good God who vomited who yakked no emotion, dear do
Alright, oh my [???] oh, oh
What?! Melt your face! Oh!
Oh
My god
I
Love it. I love it really did get more sophisticated as time went on that. I don't even remember that
Maybe I stopped playing before it
Was this one? Okay one
Oh
there that goes okay good to
potty good stuff guys good stuff
Like the ones spinning on the platform way Oh
What is this lab coats to kill alright sure, whatever you said, oh, yeah. Wow this this is not a tank this is
This is infinitely. Oh my god. Oh
my god
I'm dead. Alright, cool web. Why am I here? Wait a minute. That's not fair. We gotta get out of there. Oh my god
Hey, hey hey
Holy shit, it's turned on me
Wait, no, that's not fair. Oh god. Oh god. Let me out of the crazy ride Wow
Can't make it at the door. Oh god. Oh god. Oh god. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Oh
geez, m's, let's uh
Turn you off. Okay. Oh
Alright
Hello Oh No
Close all the trash compactors on the detention level Oh God, not the trash compactors on the detention level
and smooshy
There's just so many different ways Oh, what is this? Oh,
You're gonna love my nuts. Oh, you're gonna love my nuts Oh,
Slap chop for days. You're gonna love my nuts. Oh and good the dumps the body parts right down into the drain
That's so good. In fact, just waste good. Yeah, let's get that flow control up, please
All right. Good. Yeah there oh
Okay, oh good drown, yes, that's good, that's perfect. Okay. All right now let's do squish about safety hood
Oh, yes for safety. If you I want the safety definitely. Okay. Good good
I'm out of here my god, they're so much more to this than I remember. There's legitimately so much more to this
Hi buds, Oh bah bah. Oh, hey buds
Okay, bye-bye. Oh, it's whack-a-mole. It's- it's a game of whack-a-mole. It's a game of whack-- It's a horrible game of whack-a-mole....!
Good, great, good. See ya, see ya around buddy.
Well, this looks fun. "Stop machine before making adjustments." All right. Oh good
It's Slither.io! Oh, it's it's just a little Slither.io for everybody to enjoy. Doink. Okay, what are we?
Okay
Yeah, yeah, basically that's a weird one. Cuz basically it just explodes.
I'm gonna get really happy and jiggly when they do it. Oh
Hi, okay, let's go up
We very fun now that's that's cool. Oh
Hi
Okay, so I'm gonna be let into the blue base but then what what does that mean for me Oh, oh
My god, okay. I'm out of here. See you guys. Oh, hey and nobody's gonna get through ever again
Okay, good good, you know and go. Oh
Hello
Sorry, there's probably not a whole lot more left to the game because I don't know what other ways you could possibly slaughter
Scientists but uh, I think we might be reaching close to the end here. Oh good at HEV. Okay brutes control Oh,
Boots wait, no. I need to cross that I need it. I need to cross that please. Thank you. Okay. Goodbye
I need that. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you for that
I mean it's a scientist fault for just spawning out of nowhere
Like if they didn't just pop out of existence like that, then they wouldn't have nearly the problem that they're at it. Oh
All right. I'm in here now wherever here is and there's this thing. Oh
No, wait. No, there's no one in there. Oh
All right, okay, you could still surprise me every once in a while you could still give me the old woofer
Oh, hey is this gonna go spiraling out of control as the Rams over those scientists over there? Can I get up here, please?
Thank you. Good look out
It's like this scene from Austin Powers
You know how it was I
Don't need to quote it for you. All right, good road. Glad I glad I did that that was worth of the journey
I'm sorry who's dying?
I'm
I'm sorry. Oh
You're just standing in the middle of the road. Well, that's not that's not that's that. Okay
Well that debts not what do you want to see? Okay. Goodbye. Yay. Where is this? This looks fun. Oh
Oh shit, what did I just do what two three
Oh, oh
Oh my god
What the hell? "H-Grunt"? "H-Grunt"?. Oh
They're fight. Oh, they're dying. They're not fighting. That's a massacre. Oh, yeah, they're getting annihilated by that alien or whatever
That is put some lab coats in there. Oh
I don't know if I want to go out there. Oh boy. What did I just do? Oh, it's following the view of
Okay, all right good great. Yeah. Yeah, I'm just gonna sneak on by right this
Just
Slipping by poor god this is in the door. Okay. So the door is the door is the door is it or
Made it everything's hunky and everything is dory. Hey, it's raining Wow good. That's cool. What is that?
What is that? That is what?
What am I looking at? What's going on here? Is that a Zeppelin? Is that gonna kill people up? Yeah. Well it yeah, okay
Yep, it'sit's to death. Okay
That is a new one, I gotta admit that is most certainly a new and do doom balloon
That is so much better than the name that I came up with that is
Infinitely better than death Zeppelin that the doom balloon that makes so much sense. It hurts. Alright, cool. Goodbye
How is there more? Oh hi. Oh
All right, goodbye the first one that had the brains to run away
Thank you, oh, thank you
You know whenever I played the game I never realized that the scientists could heal you until way way after like my 15th playthrough
Hey look out behind you
OK, alright, see ya buddy
HUH? oh? OH!  OK!!!
OH! OH that's- oh!
OH! Alright, I'm just gonna keep- I'm just gona keep right on by... oookay
All right, what is this, oooo this looks fun. Oh, hey buddy! [BAM BAM]
"Surface access." Not sure what that's doing or what this is gonna do
"Take off and land"...? [GASP]
Take off. Oh, here we go. Oh, we're going. Oh, I've got a UFO I have I have a UFO
I've got a UFO. Oh
My god, oh
My
god
Let's go to warp baby warp it up. I don't know where we're going
I've no idea. I love this so much by the way. Oh my god. I'm in space
Oh
God why are you up?
Why are you out there?
What what
The mothership it's a god damn mothership. This is this is the beauty of Maude's this is the
absolute beauty of mods this is there is nothing better than
A mod that the Creator just takes to the limit of their imagination. This is
What is this? Oh
Yes, like The BFG or something like that. Okay. All right. Well, sorry buddies
Okay, all right good, sorry, okay. See ya around it is oh man Red Team only huh
Fortunately visit the edge of the map but you can't really go to the red sector
Can you oh no, are we approaching the end? Oh
No, we are aren't we? Okay good a blue team a
Any scientists out there. Whoa low grav, okay
I'm very slow
"Earth", "Zen". Let's go to earth. Oh shit. Oh,
Hey, I'm back what no, no no no no no no, no, no. No, I want to go back
No, I wanted to go back. Where did I last save? Okay here. All right. Good. Great. Good. All right everybody
Hold on to your hats. I just need to go
to Zen
Cuz that's the way forward the way I went was going backwards and I don't want to go backwards
I want to go forward cuz forwards the only way that I know to go. Oh
Never mind that that doesn't sound like the way that I wanted to go. Oh
This door died, there's a door I didn't see the door before I didn't see the door before
I thought that it wasn't a door. All right, here we go. This looks prime on fire in this very slow. This is
very slow
Oh, okay. Goodbye
Ice powers. Oh
I love it. I butthole I love it even more I
Don't know what this is - are you fighting me? Oh you wanna fight? Oh you were you gonna die
That's what you gonna do. Just fire do make concern. Could you please go practice your beam attacks somewhere else?
This platform is small enough without you blowing holes in it. Hi
Yeah, I don't think so. Whoopsies that's not where I wanted to go. Okay
Butthole Oh, what do we have here?
Where are we? Whoa, I'm back home. I made it
AYE, good for you, get frozen!
Let it go in one night hi, it's me, don't worry
Don't know why they're letting me through but they sure aren't they everything's good in my book. Everything's great in my neighborhood
Hmm. Okay, there doesn't seem to be anything else new here. He's gotta be something over here. Well, that's not
Well, congratulations, you've gone where no players gone before it as will reward
The nephilim alliances giving you residents of this bio organic waste storage chamber game over
next time don't go this far the next level won't be there until the next version of
Scientists slaughterhouse. No
That's the end
NOOO! AWw man! It's all over
Game over man
Anyway, I played this a lot more than I thought I was going to and I guess that just goes to show like how fun
It can be enough fun mods can be in general
This is just really silly and weird and kind of just bizarre and meaningless
But hey, that's kind of the point of mods. Like they're they're cool sometimes in there
They're wonderful and they're weird and I like that about them
So thank you everybody so much for watching
If you've got favourite mods that you've played in the past or that you're playing right now for whatever game
Please let me know down in the comments below
I want to know what mods you guys go to all the time
to have some fun with games that you know and love and have
Played a bajillion times and you know mods make them a little more fun and you can always go back to it for a little
Bit longer so, you know, that's pretty cool. So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down the comments and as always I will see you
in the next video. Buh bye!
*Outro Music plays*